[Applaudissements]
en tant que neuroscientifique il y a une
question qui me fascine et qui m'effraie
qu'est-ce qu'une banane
c'est une vraie question
une banane c'est jaune c'est courbé ça
c'est plus à la main avec sa peau
épaisse et ça se mange avec du nutella
et c'est ça une banane pour un
neuroscientifique ce sont les neurones
de la couleur jaune les neurones de la
forme courbée les neurones de la
sensation des plus chers la peau et les
neurones du goût du Nutella qui
s'activent dans notre cerveau
on a tous et toutes une banane dans le
cerveau
maintenant deuxième question
cette banane existe-t-elle
et bien vous n'avez aucun moyen de le
savoir
parce que ce qu'il s'est passé lorsque
vous avez vu cette banane c'est que des
photos ont rebondi sur cette banane sont
venus percuter votre rétine au fond de
votre œil qui a envoyé des signaux
électriques jusqu'au fond de votre
cerveau à l'arrière au niveau du cortex
visuel qui a activez les neurones de la
couleur jaune de la forme courbe qui a
leur tour ont activé les neurones du
concept de la banane
ou alors
ou alors un neuroscientifique s'est
branché sur l'une des étapes du circuit
et activer les bons neurones au bon
moment
et vous n'auriez aucun moyen de faire la
différence
alors vous demandez certainement comment
hacker un cerveau
bienvenue dans le petit tutoriel du
pirate cérébral
pour cette démonstration je vous demande
d'applaudir notre cobaye Suzanne
notre objectif faire voir une banane
assuzanne
commençons par hacker
s'arrêter
la rétine de Suzanne est composée de
cellules qui ont un rôle convertir les
rayons lumineux en petite impulsions
électriques
et bien nous allons court-circuiter ces
cellules
pour ça je fais une petite incision sur
le côté de l'oeil de Suzanne et j'insère
1500 câbles électriques sur une surface
de 3 mm par 3 mm
quand j'envoie une décharge électrique
à droite de la rétine de Suzanne
elle voit apparaître une tâche lumineuse
à gauche de son champ visuel
quand j'envoie une décharge électrique à
gauche de la rétine de Suzanne
elle voit une tâche lumineuse apparaître
sur sa droite
maintenant nous allons tenter de faire
voir une banane à Suzanne en envoyant
des décharges électriques au bon neurone
c'est pas de la 4K mais c'est déjà ça
et ce que nous avons accompli sur la
rétine de Suzanne on pourrait
l'accomplir sur n'importe quel chaînon
du système visuel
ou alors
on pourrait tenter d'activer directement
les neurones du concept de la banane
comment les trouver
et bien j'insère une électrode dans la
zone du cerveau de Suzanne qui code les
nouvelles mémoires
et je vais enregistrer l'activité d'un
neurone
l'activité électrique je la convertis en
son afin que nous puissions l'écouter
et nous allons voir ensemble si nous
avons trouvé un neurone de la banane
pas de réponse
la tour de Pise
Roger Federer fierté Suisse
l'actrice de Friends Jennifer Aniston
crépitement de pop-corn que nous
entendons là c'est le bruit
caractéristique d'un neurone qui
s'excite
il semble que nous ayons trouvé un
neurone qui s'excite
lorsqu'il est confronté à des actrices
alors
tentons avec Emma Watson
une autre photo de Jennifer Aniston
laissez-moi tenter quelque chose
nous avons trouvé un neurone qui
s'active spécifiquement
lorsqu'il est confronté au concept de
Jennifer Aniston
ce neurone a été découvert en 2005 chez
un patient aujourd'hui c'est
certainement le neurone le plus célèbre
du monde mais revenons à la piraterie il
y a fort à parier que si l'on avait
activé les neurones du concept Jennifer
Aniston dans le cerveau de Suzanne elle
aurait subitement pensé à Jennifer
Aniston
autrement dit il est conceptuellement
envisageable de pirater les pensées
alors rassurez-vous nous n'en sommes pas
encore là
lorsqu'il s'agit de pirater les systèmes
périphériques c'est assez facile Louis
le toucher
la vue ou le mouvement mais lorsque son
lorsqu'on s'aventure vers les fonctions
les plus complexes du cerveau
comme les pensées la réflexion la
mémoire le petit guide du pirate
cérébral devient beaucoup plus flou
et pour tout vous avouer avoir découvert
le neurone de Jennifer Aniston relève de
ce que l'on appelle en sciences un gros
coup de bol
chaque découverte en neurosciences
me confronte à une réalité qui me
fascine et qui m'effraie
je ne suis qu'une machine
chacune de mes sensations de mes
émotions de mes pensées
n'est qu'un signal électrique qui
parcourt mes neurones
un signal électrique qui peut être
piraté modifier effacer
il suffit qu'un petit grain de sable
finisse dans la machine pour qu'elle
déraille
que des neurones meurent sur le côté de
votre cerveau et vous serez incapable de
reconnaître votre petit-fils
que des neurones soient blessés dans
votre moelle épinière et vous serez
condamné au fauteuil roulant
que des neurones disparaissent au fond
de votre rétine et vous passerez le
restant de vos jours dans le noir
mais il y a une facette excitante à tout
ceci
c'est que nous sommes des machines
et qu'en tant que ma fille nous pouvons
être réparés
en étudiant et en corrigeant les
circuits cérébraux les circuits
électriques
on devient capables de commencer à
prolonger la mémoire des patients
souffrant d'Alzheimer
certains patients
paralysés
réussissent à remarcher quelque part
certains aveugles récupèrent une forme
de vision
alors
je vous entendez Suzanne je vous entends
pensez si c'est pour voir une banane
noir et blanc 60 pixels à quoi bon et
vous avez raison
mais ce n'est que le début toutes ces
technologies n'ont que quelques dizaines
d'années
aujourd'hui au moment où nous parlons
dans les laboratoires on développe des
implants rétiniens souples de minuscules
panneaux solaires qui reçoivent
directement l'énergie de la lumière et
la transforme en impulsion électrique
des yeux bioniques de haute résolution
dont la stimulation est optimisée par
intelligence artificielle
des implants capables de distinguer
entre différentes couleurs
des milliers de neuroscientifiques
travaillent à découvrir le cerveau et
inventer de nouvelles manières de le
réparer
comme eux je rêve de percer les mystères
de la machine que je suis
car
pour être honnête
on ne sait pas encore exactement ce qui
est une banane
merci
[Applaudissements]